founded in 1971 the congressional black
caucus was envisioned as a biracial
alliance of black lawmakers
so guess how many black republicans are
in the group today
zero now it's not for a lack of trying
for months congressman byron donalds has
inquired about joining
but the cbc won't give him an answer in
fact one cbc source tells buzzfeed
the group is actively blocking donald's
membership
but don't worry there's a consolation
prize a patronizing interview
with cnn's cheerful morning crew
do you think that your defense of a
person that said things like that might
be
incongruent with the mission of the cbc
first of all whatever the president said
in the past it's nothing to do with this
discussion at all
i think well you've defended you've
defended it you've defended please don't
cut me off i didn't i have not cut you
off in this interview please do not do
that to me
thank you as a black man in america i'm
allowed to have my own thoughts on who i
choose to support and who i choose not
to support
florida congressman byron donalds joins
me now congressman
uh the cbc's actions are bad enough but
then
to have the media try to justify it
by implying that you don't have the
right
to disagree with the prevailing wisdom
political wisdom of the
congressional black caucus that's
amazing
completely amazing but i'm not surprised
the media has been covering
for the democrats for quite some time
and so when they try to bring up
president trump and the things that he
has said is justification i found it to
be outrageous
because laura last time i checked i was
born black i've grown up black i've made
it i've made it in america as a black
man
i graduated college as a black man i
raised my sons as a black man i came
into the halls of congress
as a black man so i don't know what
donald trump or joe biden or frankly
anybody else has to do
with the cbc and myself but you know
like i said earlier
you know they asked me if i wanted to
join i was a member of the congressional
of the legislative black caucus when i
was in florida's legislature for four
years
so i've been through this before it was
much more congenial in florida but i'm
in washington now so we'll see how it
goes from here
you ever run into like eleanor holmes
norton or
you know any of the other members of the
cbc and
chit chat about this in the in the halls
i mean you ever talk to each other
well that's the funny thing because i've
talked to a lot of the members whether
we're on the floor
in the speaker's lobby like just in
passing and it comes up and they say hey
would you join the cbc and i said yeah
i was in the legislative black caucus
when i was in the florida legislature
for me laura it's about making sure that
conservative ideals
are actually being discussed in the room
and at the table
i know that a lot of members of the cbc
will not agree with me
and i'm not going to agree with with
them but it's about actually having the
conversation
that the left always says they want to
have i'm prepared to have it
i'm ready to sit down and discuss it but
apparently they don't want to discuss it
with me
well do you think they're worried that
if you
entered these meetings were taking part
in the meetings
that you might convince a few people to
consider issues
a little differently from a different
point of view or they don't want anyone
outside of their fold you know knowing
what they discuss
i mean it's got to be one of those two
things i mean you don't seem to be a
very threatening person i think you're
just
you kind of just wanna you want your
views heard i imagine
uh i really don't know i gotta put leave
that up to them i think the thing that's
really
been kind of a weird about this whole
situation is that you had
a member say something off the record to
a reporter and a reporter ran with it
to me we're all members of congress we
go on tv shows all the time we debate
each other in committees and on the
house floor so i don't see why we can't
have this conversation
just in front of each other and then we
go from there and part our ways if
that's what the decision is
but i don't think it's really about me
convincing any of them although
you know i'm pretty smart and i make a
good argument so i think that would
probably happen
i think it's more a matter of they're
accustomed to the way they do things in
the cbc
um i don't know if i cause a problem for
them or not but it's really about
all of black america and all of america
being exposed to
all ideas and ideologies across the
political spectrum
not just one well when you listen to
comments from people like maxine waters
she may remember she was inciting
violence during the summer
riots i mean they don't really think
that you're
authentically black i mean your skin
color is black
but to them you are not authentic
and and when you go online you you know
watch some of the speeches from
some of the radicals for them you don't
really count
your kind and they use phrases like
uncle tom maybe not to your face but
look i work for justice thomas that's
what they did that's what they did to
him
they still do to him
yeah that part frankly it just sucks
i've never had anybody bring that to my
face you know i
actually respect somebody if they
actually would say it to my face
but they don't they prefer to say it on
twitter or on instagram you get a lot of
cute little means and stuff like that
and i ignore those people
when i have conversations with with
black democrats we actually
just have a good conversation so when
this came up in the media
and you know it came up from left-wing
media when it popped up it kind of
surprised me i was like oh wow we're
here already
but that's okay let's just go ahead and
do and take care of business
right here and there when it comes to
people on the radical left
especially when it comes to white
liberals who try to make try to make me
seem like
i'm not i'm not black enough for them i
tell them walk a mile in my shoes talk
to my mom who still lives in brooklyn
new york
today congressman thank you for standing
up and thank you for just being a voice
of reason
everyone's just be able to have a
conversation across party lines
every now and then congressman thank you
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else